doctor what is more serious a head
injury or a foot injury a head
injury okay Jim you owe me 120 and Phil
you owe me
230 let's open a tab because you and me
are going to be playing more often Count
Me In nope all right what do you mean
you have plans tonight I have my
daughter tonight we're Renning
Charlotte's Web well you have to make a
choice it's either your daughter or me
my
daughter I really want honestly Michael
is for you to know it so that you can
communicate it to the people here to
your clients to whomever okay what it's
whoever not whomever it's whomever no
whomever is never actually right well
sometimes it's right Michael is right
it's a madeup word used to trick
students no actually whomever is the
formal version of the word obviously
it's a real word but I don't know when
to use it correctly not a native speaker
I know what's right but I'm not going to
say because you're all jerks who didn't
come see my band last night do you
really know which one is correct I don't
know it's whom when it's the object of
the sentence and who when is the subject
that sounds right well sounds right but
is it how did Ryan use it as an object
as an object Ryan used me as an object
is he right about that how did he use it
again it was Ryan wanted Michael the
subject to uh explain the computer
system the object you to whomever
meaning us the indirect object which is
the the correct usage of the word no one
uh asked you anything ever so whomever's
name is Toby why don't you take a letter
opener and stick it into your skull the
Bor can flatten a car engine it can cut
off your arm and crush your entire body
without skipping a beat
yeah how many people a year do you think
get their arms cut off in a Bor Bor I
hardly know her damn it Michael pay
attention man anybody want to take a
guess five bucks says it's over 50 you
really want to bet anybody ever since
March Madness ended I am so bored how
many okay you're on 10 10 people Michael
10 people would you like to be one of
them no don't worry go double or
another I don't what you guys talking
about these are very dangerous machines
down here and the upstairs workers
Michael should not go anywhere near them
yes yes but it wouldn't be the worst
thing in the world it would be the worst
thing in the world it would very much
it's a big red trash Compact and that's
very dangerous
disrespect I got it I got it only on the
rarest of occasions I go tou there is no
occasion for you to go near this stuff
okay hey hey
hey you idiot start over sir just
ordered from your favorite pizza place
Alfredo
wait Alfredo's Pizza Cafe or pizza by
Alfredo same thing
no all right you don't understand when
you all talk at the same time Oscar talk
to him Michael there's a very big
difference between these two pizza
places both in quality of ingredients
and an overall taste which one did you
order
from pizza by
Alfredo all right you know what okay
okay what is better a medium amount of
good pizza or all you can eat a pretty
good
pizza
pizza brain teaser I have two coins
totaling 15 cents one of them is not a
nickel what are they a diamond and a
nickel no I said one of them is not a
nickel but the other one is I've heard
that before okay a man and a son get
into a car accident they are rushed to
the hospital the doctor says there's no
way I can operate on this boy because
he's my son the doctor is the boy's
mother a man is found hanging from the
ceiling he stepped on a block of ice
hung himself in the ice
melted Hunter it's a polar bear because
you're at the North Pole and I also
built this table what is that Chestnut
no I think that is either Pine or Nordic
Cherry it's Pine yeah so Jim I noticed
you checking out Jan's candles oh no she
just put it in front of my face yeah did
you know the candles are the number one
fastest growing product in the Santa
Roma Market $2 billion year industry and
for only
$10,000 you could become a co-owner of
Serenity by Jam what do you think about
that thought about it I'm in I just
thought it was a kind of a flat you know
$25 onetime donation I didn't think it
was a per mile kind of deal you know so
well that's what a wathon is I know it
says it right on the sheet it's look
look at the sheet it says it's however
many dollars per mile got it yes so it
does um I just think it's kind of cheap
to undon money to a charity no no no no
no no I I wasn't that wasn't what I was
no
it's it's it's not about the money it's
just
it it's the ethics of the thing
Oscar how's your nephew is he in good
shape yeah how many miles did he do last
year last year he walked 18 miles son of
a that is impressive good for
him I have recently taken a lover well
that's great
congratulations who's the lucky lady
Pam's
mom what Pam's mom Helen remember from
your wedding you're messing with me
about what you did not have sex with
Pam's mom oh big time what kind of car
she drive she drives a green Cam and the
seats go all the way down all the way
down oh my
God oh my
God what okay never tell Pam and then
secondly good a packed a packed although
I may have have to break it tonight when
Helen and I tell Pam over
dinner you all right oh my God hey Jim
not now Toby my get the hell out of here
idiot what did I do okay as far as
dinner tonight cancel that and please
for both of our sakes never ever ever
see her again I think you're
underestimating Pam I think more than
anything she wants me to be happy no not
more than anything okay I I have a good
thing with the mom don't call her the
mom right on my way home from work then
take a different way home man I all
right hey you're going to you're going
to hurt yourself Mike stay clear Mike
get off of the lift please F now I'm
fine I'm fine here go would you look get
off oh oh
oh we'll get somebody to clean that up
where the ones that got to clean that
up damn it
Michael so she looks at me right and she
goes I'm sorry do I even know you you
after a year a year of buying lattes
from her do you believe that yes
question what's the most important
Appliance in your house meat grinder too
slow it's the
toilet hey Mike Daryl Noble
Daryl look I heard about the office
tough break I know I know well I'll land
on my feet yeah don't worry about me no
it
wasn't think we'll find him yeah I do
cuz Justice never rests tses no
poies you know what I think you're
attractive and I want to sleep with you
what about Kelly you read my mind is
this a
joke
yep hey hey hey hey this is fun a lot of
fun I know can I can I give you a
compliment I'm really impressed by how
much you've grown since I met you it's
like night day you should move down here
with me yeah we could be roommates
really we could get a dog we could go to
our read movies and who knows I mean
you're a guy I'm a girl yeah maybe in
six months six months oh okay I'm in
love with
Kelly any problems well you left the TV
on and your cat is dead
what Sparkles the white one his dad
sprinkles that was the sick one right
uhuh I thought she had more time no
Stanley can't she see I'm urinating
listen listen Stanley you don't need to
answer me now no just I want you to
think about it I am starting my own
company no I'll you're not letting me
finish and you just lost out on a
million dollars no I didn't what do you
like best about pay D oh I really don't
want to talk about it was her legs or
boobs or um she's easy to talk to I
guess and uh she's got a really good
sense of humor really mhm never gets any
of my
jokes what about you we're boobs
definitely do not go anywhere in near
the conference room done because you
have embarrassed me for the last time
today got it I'm not I'm not following
you you to morons got
it
how can I get you to stay money yeah we
all want
money but there is none in the budget so
tell me why you're really leaving
money more money more problem Stanley
you of all people should know that let
me ask you this if I were
money